this week in our school matter series
we're focusing on the price of college
admission especially when you play by
the rules many high school seniors and
their parents are waiting for decisions
from admissions offices this morning we
head to Long Beach California to meet
Gilbert Viveiros he's one of many high
school guidance counselors trying to
match prospective college students with
the best school possible so you want me
to look at what again as a college
counselor wait what I am the point
person that opens up their eyes
don't sweat it right now as to what
opportunities they may have let's find
some material from Santa Barbara
give them clarity on the admissions
process so you're able to log in yes and
maneuvering the labyrinth of college
admissions yes they can go to your
Stanford's or UCLA is your Yale's
but at the end of the day are you gonna
feel comfortable you're gonna feel
supported haha Barbara it's great to
have those strong alumni networks but
it's also a bonus when you can actually
pave your own way have you done this yes
I need to learn how to advocate for
themselves know how to be able to have
cold conversations with individuals that
they've never met we have to teach them
these skills because they're so
digitized that they don't really engage
the world as much as I for example did
that your phone number is correct
it's about inspiring and motivating and
tell him that they it's possible click
on the green arrow and that they belong
somewhere sarah Harbison is a former
associate dean of admissions at the
University of Pennsylvania and former
dean of admissions and financial aid at
Franklin and Marshall College she now
provides College counseling and advice
on her website admissions revolution
comm Sarah good morning good morning I'm
a parent who's been through this three
times now I might have helped write a
couple of college application essays I
won't confess to it
but and and whenever I was helping I I
was wondering what is it that colleges
want what are they looking for we have
to remember these admissions officers
they're gonna be reading sometimes
hundreds of applications a day thousands
a week so you want to surprise them and
you want to move them and students
should be themselves and they should be
proud of it and any student who's doing
something a little bit differently is
gonna stand out to those admissions
officers so I look for when I'm working
with students I want not just the doers
but the future Trailblazers those are
the students that admissions officers
get really excited about and let's not
kid ourselves though it has become much
more competitive even just over the past
a decade or so right absolutely
you know the admit rates at most of the
highly selective colleges at this point
are in the single digits yeah and I
remember being at the University of
Pennsylvania when the admit rate was
about 20 percent and I felt like none of
my kids I would call them kids none of
my kids are getting in and that was when
the admit rate was about 20 percent now
it's single digits are y'all looking at
our social media I mean you know a lot
of kids are thinking about that you know
it's admissions officers usually don't
have too much time to look at a
student's social media accounts but two
scenarios that they would possibly look
at at it is if the student makes it
known all over their application and
they put in links to their website or if
they're a blogger or a vlogger they
would provide it and so when admissions
officer would click on the link or just
simply that they're nosy and they have
the time and curiosity to go check
things out or check out who their
parents are sometimes that happens as
well oh we should go ahead what we had
an official from Stanford here at the
table yesterday who said that they were
surprised by this scandal because as she
put it she didn't think anybody from
Stanford couldn't be bought were you
surprised by this this this college
scandal I was not surprised why not I I
think because there are a handful of
parents across the country that not only
help their kids with little things in
the application process but that they go
too far and and sometimes they are
living out their dreams do you think
it's been going on for a long time I do
what we do become and how has it been
able to do this for so long the
admissions process at most especially
the selective colleges it's very private
it's all done behind closed doors once
in a while we would have
visitor or porter come in and observe
admissions committee and we would
basically admit everyone and spend
plenty of time talking about these great
regular kids the fact is as soon as that
reporter left or as soon as we had to
cut back because we had to make room for
other students who were well-connected
those wonderful regular kids would get
pulled out of the class you think the
schools themselves are complicit in any
way well it is up to the admissions
office right to still review that
application even if it is a recruited
athlete even if it is a well-connected
child of a celebrity or a politician it
is up to an admissions officer to read
through that application carefully in
the same way that they review every
other applicant so the best way to get
into a school do you have to have good
grades you have have to have its
outstanding extracurricular activities
what do you have to do to get into the
school of your grants so you have to be
competitive on an objective level rate
they've got to have the right classes
they have to have the right grades and
your perfect rates for these highly
selective schools and high test scores
that's just the status that's just basic
right right and it's all the other
pieces of the application that really
give it texture and flavor admissions
office label applicants has tagged and
untagged I had never heard that what is
that yeah so I used that a lot when I
write when I speak about college
admissions
if a student is a recruited athlete is a
child of a big donor or knows someone
their application is usually usually
tagged and the admissions officer even
if it's a young 22 year old admissions
officer right out of college they know
you have to be really careful with that
application and that application will
get many different sets of objects like
let this person in tags yes and they
once they get admitted they can't be
moved out of the class there is a
sculpting process that happens after all
the applications are read and evaluated
last two weeks before decision letters
go out lots of movement happens students
who are not tagged probably get pulled
out of the class to make room for more
of those tagged kids a lot of
intricacies happen behind closed doors
good to have you on to break some of
those down thank you Greg zoom are you